تحدي قوه نجاح انا روان محمد سرحان
فلسطينيه الجنسيه اردنيه الهوى عمري 24
سنه
بالبدايه انا درست توجيهي والسبت
نزل مناح
عبد العزيز
قدام بشكل كبير
درستها دخلتها على هذه المنح اخذ نظره عن
التخصصات الموجوده في حبات اخذ التخصص شوي
بعيد عن التخصصات الموجوده بالجامعات
فاختلف تخصص فاشله ديزاين تصميم ازياء
فدخلته من البدايه لحتى كملت فيه همم
بالكليه دراسات تخرجت المعظم بنات العيله
اللي درسوا معي في نفس التوجيهي والنجحه
كملوا الجامعات وقعدوا في البيت انا
بعد ما انتهت الكليه دراسه ايه تخرجت بفضل
الله وكملت طريقي ما ياست ما رجعت للياس
الي انا جدا كنت فيه بمراحل التوجيهي
فالملحه قدمت لي كثير الطريق التفاؤل
لقدام وامل اعطتني طريقه امل وتفاؤل لقدام
انا وانا صغير وكنت ابلش ارسم بس مش الرسم
الشيء اللي مثل ما انا بس هلا وصلت له همم
هسه صرت ااه ارسم التخيل اللي انا الفشن
ديزاين التخصصي صرت الفكره بخيالي على ارض
الواقع مثلا بدي اصمم فستان اتخيلوا
بخيالي
والصمم على ارض الواقع الفضل الكبير همم
كثير كثير واللي اعطاني امل كمان الطريق
ولو قدام هو فضل الوالدين
الكبير ما وقفوني بنفس الطريقه
بالعكس كانوا كثير همم معطيني مجال وراحه
لا قدام كانوا معطيني الدلال الكبير بشكل
كبير واعطوني تفائلوا بالعكس حكوا لي لا
اكمل اسيل وقت فتره التوجيهي حاجات خلاص
ما راح اكلها
ماشي يكمل بس اخترت الملحه كان دعم والدي
كثير بشكل مش طبيعي
بشكل قوي ايه لا للتخصص اعطاني دافع لقدام
همم حلمي انه اطلع اطور من نفسي كمان
وكمان اطور حالي اطلع مصممه ازياء
على معظم مستوى انحاء العالم اطلع همم
للفشن ديزاين بشكل همم بشكل عام همم طلع
اخذ نظره على همم على الفشن ديزاين همم
بشكل همم كامل اطلع لبره اطور من حالي
اعطي مسؤوليات كمان اكبر
عصير
انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]